our guest today is an emmy grammy and
tony nominated actress and musician who
is currently starring on broadway in
potus or behind every great dumbass are
several women trying to keep him alive
which is playing now at the shubert
theater please welcome to the show the
legendary vanessa williams
[Music]
oh my goodness so lux i love your sex oh
thank you
i said find some sparkle and go nuts
and they did great job so welcome
thank you thank you welcome vanessa
williams i want to be transparent about
why you're here okay you are here
because you are literally everything
there is no way to entertain people that
you are not a master of i have loved you
for as long as i can remember i honestly
believe you are the single most
underrated comedic actress of all time
technically you are an actor singer and
a producer but you're also an icon
goddess and pretty pretty princess good
lord
wow
and that's
before a drop of margarita damn i am
honored
well we love you
and everyone does
thank you for being here now
let's get into this show every comedian
i know
everyone i know has seen it loved it but
all the comedians i know who have seen
it have been like it's very funny it's
uh so potus is uh open on broadway at
the schubert it is
seven zany women on a female forest i
don't know that if that's ever been done
on broadway existed i don't know it's
all female cast susan strowman was our
director selena fillinger is a 28 year
old playwright and she wrote she started
writing this about six years ago and it
is so on point it's almost like divine
timing uh because not only are there
seven women behind the white house
making it happen
uh but uh in one particular instance uh
julian huff's um
character talks about
the importance of female reproductive
rights that are a human right and for
the first time we got a standing it
stopped the show on tuesday night after
the decision
everybody stood up on their feet and it
probably lasted a good solid minute and
a couple of us were almost in tears
because it was so resonating yeah yeah
people just want to hear another human
acknowledge the horrible thing is
horrible yeah that's it it's all in fun
though because this is a comedy it is is
as far as what we're talking about farts
means that it's zany it's wild it's it's
physical there's people sliding down
walls and blood all over the place
it's crazy female force i'm so intrigued
at somebody do the research and find it
out because i'm fixing to write the
second yes come see the show
people absolutely adore it now i play
the first lady that's right i do i do
did you get any advice from any former
first ladies about playing a first lady
actually i have met i think a total of
seven first ladies
the first one yeah when i was miss
america my first trip to the white house
was a a white house dinner in in 1983.
october 17th 1983 i remember it and i
met nancy reagan there of course
president reagan and then at that dinner
uh barbara bush and and and vice
president bush at the time and colin
powell kind of like hung out with me all
night and just was like you know just
make because i was there alone as just
miss america by myself escorted in the
room and that was it
and uh so they uh so so of course
barbara nancy and then laura bush not
the first names okay yes
hillary is not only met her several
times but she's also a neighbor because
we both live in chappaqua oh my god and
and of course michelle obama i've met
and and dined and lunched with and know
her well so hopefully i'll get at least
hillary and and michelle to come to the
show
meanwhile all those people are saying
i know vanessa williams
and people are falling alpha now you
were saying that um the show is written
by a woman directed by a woman
a lot of uh perfect women in the cast
what how has that been like what what
has that been like i've never done an
all-female production of anything so
it's empowering it's it's almost like a
secret society we had critch was which
is our one like props man man who was
there during our rehearsals he was like
the only guy in the room that we would
allow that was part of our enclave but
it's really empowering and and
extraordinary when you get up on its
feet and people come and realize our
lighting designer is a female you know
our our sound designers female of course
hair makeup it's all run by women so
it's really exciting but when you see it
up on its feet uh the only one okay
beowulf he's he's our uh who did a
beautiful production design we have a
rotating stage on like a turntable yeah
yeah so that's beowulf we allowed him to
to join the joy of the club
but um it's you know susan strowman who
is our director uh has won multiple
tonys but also a um
started as a choreographer and a dancer
so there's so much movement and a lot of
music too we have a little uh super mega
mix at the end where we're all singing
these empowering [ __ ] beat songs so uh
if you want to have a laugh if you want
to escape if you want pure silliness and
zaniness this is your show it's beyond
the play because a lot of people don't
want to see a play because they're heavy
this is this is zany it's a great way to
feel good about
everything that's happening and rachel
dratch is incredible i love her leah
deleria is hilarious i love her julianne
huff is amazing and she's making her
broadway debut because we know her as a
that's right dancer and a singer and
actress but yeah she's making a broadway
debut
julie white is incredible she's won a
tony um
and suzy nakamura is amazing and
actually she plays a gay um um uh
the pr person for the president and we
just had that happen this openly gay
yesterday so all these things
yeah press secretary
so all these all these things that are
happening in the news are exactly what
you're gonna see that were written six
years ago when selena first came up with
it it's it's a it's kind of eerie oh my
gosh i'm very excited to see it
are you prepared for rapid fire
questions
yes here we go yes if they're not too
hard what they're all very easy okay and
they have specific correct answers and
you will get one no i'm just kidding
have you ever been booed
yes
um and actually i mean
the short of it i was booed
when um as miss america after i resigned
and i was out on the streets in a
festival i had a woman boom me because
she she felt that i was um a scoundrel
and and
she felt ashamed to to see me do you
have her address i do not
this was we're talking 1984 so i do not
have i don't know who she was but
haha success is that
[Applause]
you move on
how many times a day do you look in the
mirror and say i'm vanessa
[Laughter]
now normally it's like oh god what am i
going to do
so yeah i'm aging
my kingdom for this face
no you worked on ugly betty for four
seasons tell me yes
tell me one secret about america
ferreira
she is obsessed with karaoke she will
she will out sing anybody she loved
that's her jam she loves to do karaoke
that's what i wanted you to say
who would you like to play on broadway
well i mean my favorite role would have
been anita and west side story just
because i grew up with it i love it it's
sassy i just ariana dubose just came to
our show last night who just won
an oscar for which is amazing um but i'm
too old for that so there's something
yet to come you are not and you are
wrong
who should i play on broadway oh
you know what you are talented and
outspoken
you are
irreverent
huh
i don't know maybe you i i actually got
a chance to see whoopi goldberg in 1984
when she did her one woman show that's
what you need to be doing on broadway
putting it out there
okay
you're wrong the correct answer is the
dentist from little shove aboard
steve martin did it
what is the fanciest thing you do
like i imagine you
have a cat the cat's very fluffy and you
pour the thing avion water
to drink out of a crystal bowl i have
two great danes that are very slobbery
and dirty yes that sleep in my bed so oh
my gosh
vanessa williams she's one of us
[Applause]
guess what
potus is playing now at the schumer
theater go see it and stick around we'll
be right back
[Music]
you